QAnon friendly radical Trumpy in Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
said she doesn't believe in evolution during
a bonkers off the wall interview with Steve
Bannon on his so-called War Room program. Now,
I want to be really clear here. If you want to
simply see this as it's just another nutty thing,
Marjorie Taylor Green said and leave it at that,
you can do that. But understand that the world
sees what I am about to play for you and the world
is shocked, the civilized world anyway. How does
the United States still have people in the House
and Senate forget about people who deny climate
change? That ship has sailed, but we still have
people in the House and Senate who deny evolution.
And I want to get into a little bit later the
terminology of don't believe in evolution. We're
going to get to that because that's a problem to
the context was apparently covid-19 and the lab
leak theory and it caused Marjorie Taylor Green
to casually drop in that she doesn't
believe in evolution. OK, let's listen.
Speaker 4: Hang on. You don't buy that. You don't
buy the argument that say the gain of function is
all because we've got to take these viruses and we
got to power them up to look for vaccines and to
look for other solutions in case somehow they come
up with this. You don't buy it, you don't buy the
logic of that. Is that what you're saying?
Speaker 3: No, I don't buy it because I
don't believe in evolution. I
don't believe in that type of
so-called science. I don't believe in evolution.
I believe in God. And there's these viruses.
We're not making people sick until they created
them and made them into weaponize these viruses
to be able to attach to to our cells and make
us sick. This has caused so many people to die
all over the world. This is a bio weapon.
Speaker 1: All right. So the terminology,
she doesn't believe in evolution. So the virus
couldn't have evolved, but she believes in God,
but then says the virus was created by them,
meaning China. But how could China create anything
if everything is God's creation? That's crazy,
incoherent. I don't even want to focus about
that. A focus on that today. That's not that's
crazy. But I don't want to focus on that. This
is an outrageous rant and it's an ignorant screed.
But understand that this is a member of the United
States Congress voted in by her constituents in
the state of Georgia. When I first saw this story,
I scrolled by and I thought it said, oh, Marjorie
Taylor Greene says she doesn't believe in
education. That's not actually the headline,
but it might as well be. So let's talk about
belief in evolution. I hate it when people say
this. Maybe it's you don't accept evolution.
It might more accurately be you don't understand
evolution, but don't believe in evolution. It
seems it makes it seem as though it's an issue
of faith. Imagine if someone didn't believe in
gravity, we'd say, well, what difference does it
make? You have no choice but to accept it and to
exist in a physical world in which gravity
is a reality. You might not understand it,
but to not believe in gravity sounds as idiotic
as you imagine it to be. And so when people say,
I don't believe in evolution, it should really be
thought of in. The exact same way it should sound
just as strange to us, she doesn't understand
it. She apparently wants to keep other people
from understanding it. But the main point here
is if I said I don't believe the sun is the
source of heat on the surface of the earth. I
might not accept it, I might not understand it,
but the reason I can go outside and it's a
temperature that is suitable for human life
is that it is the reality. It doesn't matter
whether I understand it or accept it or believe
in it. It's really dumb to say I don't believe the
sun heats up the earth. And it's really dumb to
say I don't believe in evolution. People who say
it should be seen the same way as people who say,
I don't believe in gravity. I don't believe
the sun heats the earth. These views should be
ostracized and they should be called out. But the
most important part is this should disqualify you
from from being an elected official. If you don't
accept or understand or believe, then to use their
term something this uncontroversial, how can you
be trusted to do anything about any issue ever?
Now, one funny thing, if anything were to make me
question evolution, it would sort of be Marjorie
Taylor Green. What I mean by that is life has
evolved for millions and millions of years.
We come out of the ocean and down from the trees
and we develop medicine and science and Netflix
and technology and air travel. And yet somehow
Marjorie Taylor Green still exists. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding. But I'm also sort of not, if
you understand what I'm saying, horrifying
that this is what we have. We have four
hundred and thirty five members of Congress.
And she doesn't understand or accept evolution,
to use her words, she doesn't believe in it,
it's a global humiliation, my
friends, and it must be changed.